welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the amazing spider-man rebooted
the spider-man franchise with a more
edgy peter parker
and a glenn stacy that they clearly
can't wait to kill
no yeah i can't see me leaving you're
dead i'm gonna throw the window now
wherever you fall on the spider spectrum
you probably have some mixed feelings
about these two movies but director mark
webb did sneak in some
fascinating details that i didn't catch
before our subscribers requested that we
revisit the past spider-man films so
let us explore everything that you might
have missed in the amazing spider-man of
the changes it made to the franchise and
its hidden meaning
there is one okay the opening flashback
shows peter parker playing hide and seek
with his father
richard parker mark webb designed this
as a metaphor for the film to follow
peter's journey to find his father but
in the end finding himself
what's your name you don't know my name
no i know your name
i just want to know if you know your
name and their teacher later codifies
this theme
there were only 10 different plots in
all of fiction there is
only one who am i oh movie teachers
always working their lesson plans around
exactly the theme the character needs to
learn
instead of what we actually learn in
high school like french verb conjugation
titties that can't be the theme of a
movie
peter's father relationships is one of
the many changes they made to the
character's mythology
instead of an orphan who never knows his
parents loses his uncle and gains powers
all
seemingly by chance this film hints at a
greater conspiracy behind it all
peter's father worked with oscorp the
same animal genetics research division
that led to his bite and to his
antagonist's deformity a deleted scene
even suggested peter was enhanced on
purpose
do you have any idea what you really
are in this opening scene peter's toy
dinosaur is visible on the table which i
guess you could argue kind of
foreshadows his coming battle with
richard's colleague kurt connors a
lizard
whom new yorkers later do describe as a
dinosaur there may not be a dinosaur
running around manhattan but there is
something more dangerous
our first image of teenage peter shows
him pinning up the debate team photo
where gwen stacy's visible there
he takes a basketball to the head
humiliation that'll later pay
back to flash after toby mcguire's
classic nerd and boy scout take on the
character
andrew garfield's peter is an outsider
by choice
he embraces his anonymity and the
identity of an internet troll is kind of
what he seems to enjoy the most when he
first becomes spider-man
the school ant-man reprimands him keep
it off the ground peter's skateboard is
later broken
he does have a whole bunch of others to
replace it though but keep it off the
ground is the advice he takes as he
becomes spider-man
uncle ben is martin sheen in this movie
aunt may is sally field originator of
one of my favorite running bits the
whole time
and peter instead of beginning the movie
as a four eyes who sheds them when his
vision
improves as spider-man this one begins
with contacts
and then puts on his father's glasses to
look more like him
a costume that he will continue to wear
as he follows in his dad's research
until he sheds this layer and takes on a
new skin in peter's bedroom are a poster
for the hitchcock film
rear window which is about a loner who
spies in the world through a lens much
like peter does
and a poster of donald glover from
community fans pushed for donald glover
to be cast as spider-man in a reboot
and he did later make cameos in
homecoming and into the spider-verse
peter's search results show up a source
from the daily bugle online
later there's a print version of the
paper and a tv banner and his connor's
research includes an article titled
osborne where is he about the
disappearance of norman osborn osborne's
face
remains in shadow in the oscorp welcome
screen
the plan was to have chris cooper play
norman in the third film that never
happened
oscorp's tree of life display includes a
rhino
a nod to the villain the rhino being
introduced in the sequel also hinting
that his powers could have also stemmed
from oscorp after the bite on his neck
peter
man spreads on the subway and envisions
flashes of the spider-man logo
on his skateboard and then magically the
stunt guy who hits him with the
skateboard switches from black to white
i don't know
the spider-man power and then one of the
related search terms for richard parker
is
richard parker life of pie a nod to the
name given to the tiger in the life of
fight novel and the 2012 film
in which dr ratha actor in this movie
irfan khan
darden and in this movie he later says
the name richard parker
richard parker wore it well and used a
cheap suit it's also worth noting that
tiger is peter's comic nickname so this
is kind of like
one tiger trying to be more like his
daddy tiger peter begins to display
agility and parkour
hanging out on the roof catching falling
mugs and ruining basketball for
everyone flash here wears the same
number
two as the guy on the subway whom peter
also took a number two on peter spends
the day swaying from chains to coldplay
and help at dr connors become the lizard
that he breaks his promise to uncle ben
to pick up aunt may
but your father lived by a philosophy a
principle really
he believed that that if you could do
good things for other people you had a
moral obligation to do those things
not choice responsibility ah the famous
uncle ben quote
paraphrased though to be fair the
original quote in the comics wasn't
spoken by uncle ben it was first
written in the narration box t-bone the
clerk is an [ __ ]
but daddy didn't give you enough milk
money today steve saw cutting the promo
actually
t-bone is the name of a low-level
gangster spider-man and blade saved from
vampires in comics and he weirdly says
daddy didn't give you enough milk money
another twist of the knife of peter's
daddy issues
and a reminder that peter apparently
didn't give much a [ __ ] about his mom
peter lets the mugger go
hey little help not my policy leading it
to uncle ben's death when ben tries to
stop this guy he actually did shoot an
alternate version that's less like the
raimi film
in which ben is out looking for peter
and he sees the smugger thinks it's
peter and follows him into the shadowy
alley
which would have been pretty interesting
to see peter live with that guilt of ben
dying because he couldn't tell the
difference between peter and a criminal
i know this is a lot to process so let's
shift gears to something smaller more
digestible more compact
like the most discreet front pocket
while at the ridge thanks to the ridge
for sponsoring this episode the ridge
helps you carry what you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet through
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want to make the most out
of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
carbon fiber it has a clean
stylish look it's chainsaw proof so when
all those
tiki hating jerks come at you with
chainsaws their attacks will be
not very effective this is their
aluminum tiki wallet they do have other
colors like matte cobalt blue or
forged carbon fiber all of them they're
light they're strong they're
ready to party but only with the minimal
amount of cash that you brought with you
because you don't need to bring
everything they make it easy to buy with
free shipping and free returns and a
lifetime guarantee it's got
thirty thousand five star reviews so you
know they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags with rfid blocking pockets and
optional device charging batteries
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code new rockstars
find the link in the video's description
peter hunts down the mugger wearing a
ramone's shirt maybe a nod to the
ramones covering the spider-man animated
theme song
and including it as a hidden track on
their vinyls and then peter falls into a
wrestling ring where he's inspired by
this wrestling mask a nod to his origin
wrestling with crusher hogan in the
comics peter orders oscorp's webbing
cable pellets
which he saw earlier on the assembly
line he engineers his own web shooters
another change from rainey's organic
wrist webbing though i'm not sure how
peter would be able to
afford these maybe he shipped them to
himself during his time in the lab with
connors but he does complete his own
custom-made suit the building he's
standing on here
is new york's met life building the
real-life location of the mcu used for
avengers tower
avengers also came out this year in 2012
and it was supposed to feature this
movie's
oscorp tower in its skyline kevin feige
was an executive producer in both movies
unfortunately columbia didn't get back
to marvel with the approval
in time but despite this suit peter is
not yet
the spider-man hero it's evidenced by
his bratty smack talk he's got a mind
of the true scholarship my weakness it's
small knives isn't funny
while this deadpool-esque sass is
definitely part of peter's teenage
identity and sense of humor
problem is we haven't yet seen peter be
a true hero yet hasn't saved any cats so
right now he's just kind of a dick but
that hero moment comes later in a really
cool way
peter arrives at gwen's via her fire
escape window kind of a
peter and wendy type arrival there and
on her shelf is the seabiscuit novel
the movie seabiscuit is what toby
maguire starred in between his first two
spider-man movies nearly caused him to
have to sit out of the second one due to
back injuries the stacy's dine on
branzino
the fish that flash in spider-man
homecoming later references
i know when bronzino's fresh and that
was not fresh okay and peter reveals
himself to gwyn as spider-man by
whipping her in for a kiss kind of
copying a move from indiana jones when
he whipped willie in for a smooch and
temple of doom
on the williamsburg bridge dr ratha's
driver is a cameo by michael papa john
the mugger and car thief in the raimi
films and in what i think is the film's
best moment
peter saves the kid from the hanging
burning car by giving him his mask
put it on the mask it's gonna make you
strong peter reunites his kid jack not
with his mother but with his
father in a sense saving himself the
lost son from his father he gets a
glimpse of this father-son reunion that
he wants so
deeply and in this moment peter finally
knows who he
is who are you john cena
oh come on this is an important moment
who is he really spider-man yes that's
who he is he's not john cena are you
sure about that and in whipping this
father and son back together peter also
thwips a critical bond that will save
his ass later
when this same guy returns to favor as
the crane operator who supplies peter
with his path to victory peter ruins
another sport for everyone
and peter fights the lizard in the sewer
one detail i really like about the
lizard is that conor's right hand has
four fingers while his left hand has
five that is because his left arm was
just his normal human arm
with the five fingers turning to
reptilian flesh whereas his right arm
fully regrew from the stump as a new
monstrous reptile limb connors attacks
peter at his high school emerging in the
tattered lab coat
just like the lizard's appearance in the
comics stanley cameos is a librarian
oblivious to everything and peter throws
gwen out the window and catches her
setting up why he assumes he'll be able
to catch her this way in the second
movie instead of
you know when peter follows connor's
into the bathroom notice how the camera
lingers on that clawed fire blanket
dispenser that is because the deleted
scene would have shown peter finding
connors reverted to his human self
in that blanket and taking pity on
connors instead
now connors just like escapes back to
the sewers despite
nearly accomplishing the whole point of
him attacking the school to kill peter
i know it's just one of many of rees
ivan's great scenes that were cut from
this film unfortunately conor's plan is
to use the gennali device
mentioned earlier to turn everyone into
reptiles via this green mist it's the
same color scheme as the vapor that
created green goblin in the rainby film
but after getting some help from new
york's crane operators union peter
applies the anti-reptile move he brought
up earlier
because of the cold blood would they
react to sudden changes in temperature
using liquid nitrogen to freeze the
cold-blooded lizard as he and captain
stacy take him down
and dispensing the antidote to turn all
those swat guys back into humans and as
captain stacy bleeds out he gives
peter back his mask just as peter gave
the kid back the mask to save him make
him feel strong and he makes peter
promise
to leave gwen out of it of course peter
doesn't
connors is arrested and a post-credit
scene reveals him in prison with a man
in the shadows revealed in the next film
to be
the gentleman who will set up the
sinister six in the movie that never
happened peter attends gwen's dad's
funeral from afar
but flash went fly shut up no matter the
cinematic universe flashes
always pay their respects peter's final
heroic swing through the city flings
them past a pair of yellow pants that
some fans say
must belong to the shocker sure really
the cool detail comes right after he
shoots himself out of that crane like a
cannonball and the camera matrix freezes
with spider-man
over the george washington bridge
famously the setting of the death of
gwen stacy at the hands of green goblin
in the comics
another reminder of the dark place this
is all headed
and yeah go for the turkey let's show
boom you looking for this
or some of my deeper opinions on how
this movie improves upon the raimi
trilogy
while also kind of ruining a generation
of superhero movie fans
into thinking anything cringe is evil
join our official discord server by
becoming a patreon at
patreon.comrockstars our next watch
along is coming up
you can join us for it there follow me
on instagram at eavos follow new
rockstars on socials and subscribe to
this channel and let's pause to remember
the moment flash
threatened a girl for just painting him
a banner you did that on purpose flash
no but i should have you better watch
your back
[Music]
you